ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi sono
particolarmente contento perché
finalmente dopo diciamo la grandissima
debacle e della scorsa settimana nella
quale abbiamo tentato di fare una
carbonare al microonde mostrando
effettivamente la scarsissima
professionalità e gusto di questo canale
oggi abbiamo deciso invece di fare
l'esatto opposto
non è come quando non si può dire è un
po volgare come battuta ma andiamo
avanti
partiamo subito con una ricetta che io
mi ricordo che da piccolo al ristorante
la ordinavo sempre sempre perché ero
pazzo di questo piatto passo il filetto
al pepe verde finalmente lo diciamo
passo è quella cosa che non credere mai
di poter fare a casa e oggi invece
scopriremo se non mi sono sbagliato fino
a questo momento possiamo dire
finalmente inalmente localmente in che
senso
andavo a mangiarci qualcosa di decente
sperando che ci è sembrato quello giusto
per voi siete i bagni a pulire ingorgato
ressora ho fatto un bello stronzone
aspetto
e ancora lì terminare cosa ci tengo a
dire che naturalmente questa ricetta non
l'ho pensata io ma al contrario un sacco
di programmi di cucina questo web che
copiano in giro senza mai dire da chi
stanno copiando shade noi ci teniamo
sempre a ringraziare diciamo chi ci ha
ispirato sono tanti in realtà ai video
che fanno questo tipo di ricetta è
finito per viverne molto al pil per il
filetto al pepe verde molto più famoso
di quanto non si pensi ma in questo caso
stiamo utilizzando la ragazza comunque
sempre luca giurato sempre poi stiamo
utilizzando dicevo la ricetta di un
ragazzo super simpatico e carino di
giallo zafferano
per prima cosa avremmo bisogno di
filetto me lo ricordavano pure in un dm
su instagram effettivamente una cosa
interessante da dire visto che parlo
spesso di plastica se stiamo attenti
anche al consumo della carne che ci
crediate o no è una delle maggiori cause
di inquinamento se credete
nell'inquinamento seccamente nel
surriscaldamento globale
altrimenti continuate a divenne la
meravigliosa piatta superficie che sale
dell'himalaya per forza sempre
dell'himalaya pena nel rosa non è buono
brodo di carne panna per face delle vere
là dentro c'è ve lo prometto
pane è un alimento magico per quanto mi
riguarda succhi di anziano altrimenti
chiamata marmellata ciman senape di
digione burro loro utilizzano il burro
chiarificato e noi abbiamo fatto che
cos'è il burro chiarificato signori per
favore farina 00 sempre fisso farina due
zeri brandy che abbiamo preso dalle
riserve di mia zia non sappiamo nemmeno
se si e brandy ma forse una cosa che si
avvicina di più al brandy assolutamente
puro svago e infine lui il pepe verde in
salamoia
dai dai dai che ci contiamo di
professionalità per una volta nella vita
prendiamo innanzitutto vi chiedo scusa
ragazzi ci continuano a dimenticare il
grembiule da sette anni questa qui a un
certo punto sa camminerà anche uno
strano resto del milan tutte le fazioni
o in un cimitero che ci ha fatto non lo
voglio sapere non lo voglio sapere
prendiamo i trefiletti ma perché proprio
breve abbiamo perché voi volete magna
ogni volta quanto ne costate rendiamo
dello spago
ora lui faceva uno strano giro che
spiegava ma a me sinceramente va di
farlo di testa mia
ma lui consiglio paolo che noi non
facciamo proprio così lo sa è un e se
non lo fa dovrebbe fare le cose piegate
a metà lo passate attorno alla carne e
qua lo fate congiungere tipo cappio a
questo punto dividete i due fili tirati
e poi riunite da un altro lato bravo
oggi mi faccio stare zitti c'è oggi
tutte le cose che mi sono state dette
ansie cucinare anno sembrava oggi vede
rimangiate per le portate stanotte a
letto avrete degli incubi 2 filippi al
posto degli occhi che vengo a cercare
infariniamo solamente il sopra e il
sotto così erika zanetti ha mangiato il
presule disco e per le cover a 22 i
filetti a posto
le riprese saranno più sta cambiando
sempre contro nessuno ma è bello l'unica
cosa speciale che ci sarà in questa
giornata voglio dire le riprese
continuano in cucina vi chiedo scusa se
saranno ancora un pochino le fa enrico
piccole pazzesche indimenticabili si ok
preparatevi a rimanere delusi è sembrato
ripresa situazione benvenuti nella mia
cucina in realtà bisognerebbe prendere
una padella dei conti non avere una
padella all'interno della mia casa
quindi accontentare di una casseruola
prima cosa da fare è schiantarci dentro
un panetto praticamente di burro e
accendere il fuoco
quello è sbagliato cioè tu non conosci
con nel cast natura qualità mia però
come conosce bene i fratelli di casa
niente
anche loro sono quattro e uno come
questi non funziona una risposta sempre
pronta vedo quanto sognavo di usare
queste non potete capire la musa e mario
li stai sfaldando ma non dice che devi
fa riscaldare molto la padella far da
quanto calore i filetti essendo molto
molto alti erano bisogno di essere
sigillati la carne quindi dovrà essere
cotta per due minuti da un lato poi da
un altro e poi messa tutta quanta sul
bordo tipo in italia carne sica
utilizzare il termine che proprio usare
ero io volevo dire sigillare city
che odore di burro io non so però è
abituato a cucinare col burro non si
diletti al burro verde abbassare un po
la fiamma panizzi asp ricordare un botto
e i turni la farina non lo so cosa non
ti dirò hai fatto tipo l'impanatura ma
che è male hai sbagliato pure sta riceva
una piscina di sopra regala al dio santo
io di cucinare e cucinare con i giudici
che xfactor masterchef io non va affatto
cantano innanzitutto mammamia rega è
pesante come forse perché deve essere
chiarificato aspettiamo che di certo
entusiasmante ha variato dalla fiamma
orava rialzata la fiamma sulle mani giù
le mani dai ma è un villaggio turistico
allora a questo punto vado faccio faccio
di testa mia inizia a mettere i filetti
su un lato domino l'obiettivo non è
burro e farina
vengo da caracas dovevo fare devi fare
il clan begu dobbiamo dar fuoco
devi fare la club ma che esponiamo e che
prende fuoco si sono nemmeno una padella
io per farlo ti nascondi fa ridere
vedere che cos'è la farina dai ragazzi
non è che si può avere tutto quanto
dalla vita profilati funziona così
ma io devo togliere tutta immobili
infiammabile non lo so ok quanto brandis
oa 25 grammi andato
un altro po ok stop ma come si fa a
effettiva gara centro si può dire è
perfetta e sicuro senti sta sfumando
presentato ma a me è sembrato basta a me
è sembrato che incominciate a essere
spiacevole
secondo me hai sbagliato ad averti qui
oggi non è riversata nella carne
rispondiamo al brand avevo è meglio cosa
che ci ubriachiamo sapere da fuoco basta
facile famiglia suonando insieme
all'alcol è evaporata la mia pazienza
veicolo 20 all 1
la senape bike poi aggiungiamo due terzi
di questa panna ok ok strane avevamo
cominciando un attimo alla pari i
filetti e prendiamo a questo punto i
filetti li mettiamo da parte e
teoricamente dovrebbero ora li lasci un
attimo riposare perché così su chi si i
succhi diffondono va bene quello che
devo farci solo te lo tieni a questo
punto mettiamo il brodo
alzati favola temperatura mi sembra
stava facendo una delle ricette più
confusionari e della storia di questo
form
andiamo a togliere il filo mantova
questo tema enrico continuato primi
dubbi sulla cottura
mi resta il filetto per te
no no no stiamo cercando di far vedere
se funziona o no questa ricetta di
conquistare così oddio magari dai canali
e mamma mia il pressing
no non si alza mai da dal fornello il
gratuito liste alzando fino non si
chiarirà figlio sono tre mesi e oggi
quello che suggeriscono è che nel
momento in cui tu tracciando una linea
vedrai il fondo della padella è questo
che si ricongiungerà lentamente saprai
che l'acqua crema è pronta come nel
nostro caso quindi prendiamo un filetto
non mettiamo qui magari gli togliamo lo
spago del piatto è un errore gravissimo
vari se e che cosa succede che lo
rimandi in cucina rimandano in cucina
guarda come lo faccio mangiare quindi
diritti sterile cose sempre in a me lo
sono mi chiedo come di rimbalzo
la mia autostima finalmente al volo
faccio gli altri che passiamo
all'assaggio vai vai
siamo arrivati al momento dell'assaggio
prima di farlo però con loro due che
sbavano e continuano a diluire la
salsina verde con la loro salina volevo
ricordarvi che se vi è piaciuto questo
video potete sempre iscrivervi a questo
canale per darci una mano a metterci un
bel pollice su per il soprattutto perché
questo è il pensiero altri commenti chi
avete trovato più
dura io che ho fatto non avere un filo
puoi rimandarlo indietro considera è 40
difficile di me sarà difficile dormire
infatti stasera sapendo di aver perso
una stella michelin
a questo punto di nei ragazzi di
assaggiare facciamo troppa gente la
faccia stranissima legate troppo sono
purtroppo sera ha detto al video se ti
ho detto basta
ma se la vera se possiamo avere la
regola md journal come diceva queste una
cane forse non so se troppo cosa posso
dire la farsa è venuta male
la carne è venuta bene ma la preferisco
più cruda
nel complesso è buono tra il 6 e il 7
marino section sente più la carne si
sente che buona canguro non burro
chiarificato in fable non si sente più
anche della birra noi continuiamo a fare
io ho respirato il pepe grazie per aver
portato la birra e un popolo appena una
settimana prossima sempre domenica alle
12 un'altra puntata di fucile buttare
ciao
tra cui c'era poteva venire meglio si
poteva finire peggio
così abbiamo spesso ma che cos'è spedita
a casa vianello questa